Pour l'été, voici une vidéo bonus
un petit peu "Summer", un petit peu "Chill"
en gros c'est une reprise acoustique de mon morceau "Assassin des Templiers"
avec mes potos
donc moi je sais pas chanter, hein moi je sais faire que des blagues
par contre mon pote Mike il sait très bien chanter, et mon pote Waxx il fait très bien de la guitare
Donc on mélange tout ça, et ça donne ceci :
Si vous aimez mettez un petit "Thumb to the TOP"
Wou ! Wou !
Assassin des Templiers
J'arpente les rues, sapé comme un moine
Lame dans la manche, tueur dans l'âme
Dans l’anonymat, j'mène une vie semée d’embûches
J'suis personne, caché sous ma capuche
Quand j'suis dans la foule...
J'suis sous ma capuche
Quand j'assassine...
Quand il pleut...
J'suis sous ma capuche
Quand j'suis sous ma capuche,
j'suis sous ma capuche
Ouais mais ce que t'as pas dit,
c'est que ta capuche c'est surtout pour cacher ta calvitie
Là on dirait juste Gérard Jugnot
Baby
Parmi les Templiers
Je sais m’immiscer
Je suis déguisé
et ma lame est aiguisée
Un inconnu sombre
toujours dans la pénombre
Je me fonds dans la foule
discret comme une ombre
Sauf que là mec t'es dans une foule d'enfants
et tu mesures 1m85
tout le monde te voit baby
même l'instituteur
J'fais des trucs un peu malsains
j'mène une vie d'assassin
à éliminer sans pitié
les Templiers
J'fais des trucs un peu malsains
j'mène une vie d'assassin
à éliminer sans pitié
les Templiers
Je grimpe sur les toits
J'arpente les abbayes
Tout en acrobatie, Yamakasi
Quel héros à part moi
peut grimper, frapper, tuer, escalader des cathédrales
avec un style oriental ? Prince of Persia
Ouais c'est vrai mais
moi j'suis quand même fort hein !
Et en plus lui il peut remonter le temps
Bon ok mais moi j'ai un grappin
D'accord ?
Seul contre tous, j'me bats un contre vingt
Coup de pied circulaire, lame dans la jugulaire. Esquive,
high kick, esquive, middle kick, parade
uppercut, tomahawk. J'te rappelle que t'es branché
à l'Animus et dans la vraie vie
t'es seul chez toi en slip, sur ton canapé
on voit ton paquet...
J'fais des trucs un peu malsains,
J'mène une vie d'assassin
à éliminer sans pitié
les Templiers. Malgré cette vie hors-norme, au fond de moi j'reste un homme
Alors parfois j'monte en haut d'un clocher et mélancolique, je médite
Je pense à ma vie longuement, en contemplant la ville, longuement.
Ouais mais prends pas trop ton temps mec parce qu'en bas y a
les pompiers qui pensent que tu veux te suicider
Ils ont même déjà tendu un drap
Woh ouh wah
T'en fais pas pour moi,
je connais les bails, après mon saut de l'ange,
j'atterris dans la paille
Si je peux me permettre, cette paille est un peu mouillée
et elle va coller à tes vêtements
tes vêtements...
Bon tu vas la boucler toi ! Tu connais pas ma vie ok. Tu sais pas qui j'suis
J'fais des trucs un peu malsains
J'mène une vie d'assassin
à éliminer sans pitié, les Templiers
Wou ! Wou !
Assassin des Templiers ! Wou ! Wou ! Assassin des Templiers !
Assassin des Templiers
Wou ! Wou !
Woop Gang !
*Norman à la guitare, Waxx à la guitare et Mike à l'harmonica*
Ma lame va t'faire regretter la vie qu'tu as menée
Les choix que tu as faits au sein des Templiers
J'vais faire couler ton sang tellement abondamment que même Dexter
trouverait ça badant. Dexter
n'a rien à voir
là-dedans, c'est juste une série américaine
Et là tu m'tues pas
Nan nan nan, c'est la version acoustique
J'fais des trucs un peu malsains
J'mène une vie d'assassin
à éliminer sans pitié, les Templiers
J'fais des trucs un peu malsains
Je mène une vie d'assassin
à éliminer sans pitié, les Templiers
Norman Thavaud, Mike Kenli et Waxx